All right, it's Gemini day. Gemini 3.1 Pro is here.
Let me just show you the most important benchmark.
This is Pelican Bench, how well a model can draw
a pelican riding a bicycle using SVG.
Let's look at the progress from Gemini 3.0 to 3.1.
Generate an animated SVG of a pelican riding a bicycle.
And as you can see, it is much better,
much more fluid motion, but that's not all.
We also have a frog on a vintage penny-farthing bicycle.
Look at this.
This one doesn't even make sense at all,
but this one, very good.
Next, we have a giraffe driving a tiny car.
Boom, there's just so much more detail,
so much more movement.
It looks great.
Here's an ostrich on roller skates.
These are incredibly important benchmarks.
This is basically AGI.
This one is incredibly impressive, jokes aside.
And we also found out the Gemini 3 DeepThink model
that just came out last week was yes, in fact, using Gemini 3.1 Pro as the underlying model.
And today they are shipping 3.1 Pro across their consumer and developer products to bring this
progress and intelligence to your everyday applications. I can't wait to test this in
OpenClaw. All right, let's look at some benchmarks. This one is crazy. Look at this.
Humanity's last exam with no tools scores a 44.4% with search, with a block list. Basically,
don't get the exact answers and coding with an environment 51.4.
That is a substantial increase from Gemini 3 Pro and basically the same score as Opus 4 a little bit better with no tools a little bit worse with tools But it also absolutely dominates on Arc AGI 2 If you not
familiar with that benchmark, it's a benchmark that tests the model's ability to acquire new
skills through learning and generalize them quickly. Here's what that looks like. You have
an initial pattern. It gives you the solved version of it. Then it gives you a new version
and says, solve it. Shout out to friend of the channel, Greg Cameron, also president of ArcPrize.
So we have it scoring a 77.1%. That is double, more than double of Gemini 3 Pro. That is
absolutely beating everything else. Opus 4.6 coming in somewhat close at 68.8%. This is
substantial. Another absolute domination, GPQA Diamond. This is scientific knowledge with no
tools 94.3 second was gemini 3 pro at 91.9 and coming in third 92.4 gpt 5.2 thinking extra high
we have a fantastic coding score with sweet bench verified 80.6 basically tying opus 4.6 scoring a
number of points ahead of gemini 3 pro here's what's actually super interesting sonnet 4.6
Anthropix mid-tier model scores incredibly well across the board here.
I said it before when I reviewed it, it is an absolute workhorse for knowledge work.
Now here's the thing.
It is quite expensive.
It is less expensive than Opus 4 but it is still very expensive And if I really being honest it is my favorite model right now because it has a great personality It is fantastic at tool calling It has a million token context window
but boy, is it expensive.
And that's why I'm not using it
as my primary model in OpenClaw.
Live Code Bench scored really well.
SciCode, number one.
T2 Bench, which is agentic tool use,
scored nearly perfect, 99.3 in telecom.
MMLU, multilingual Q&A scored incredibly well.
So just a very high scoring model, but we all know
benchmarks only tell part of the story.
It's all about the vibes.
It's all about when you actually go to use it,
how well does it perform?
I actually briefly switched to Gemini 3 Pro
as my primary model in OpenClaw,
while Anthropix so meanly revoked my access
to using it via OAuth, and I really liked it.
I really liked Gemini 3, so I can't wait to try out 3.1.
So 3.1 Pro is designed for tasks
where a simple answer isn't enough,
taking advanced reasoning and making it useful
for your hardest challenges.
So here are a few more SVG examples.
I don't know why they're so focused on SVGs,
but it is so clearly better than Gemini 3 at SVG creation.
Look at this chameleon as compared to this one on the right,
just so much more detail, just the visual design,
the ability to create really compelling, beautiful SVGs is just so much better.
Here is a simulation of something called murmuring which is basically how a flock of birds fly together in these crazy cool patterns in the sky Watch this So this is a complete simulation of that written by Gemini 3 Pro And Jeff Dean
one of the best engineers in the world, the chief scientist at Google DeepMind, put together a few
of his favorite use cases. Check this out. So he says, I've always been interested in urban
planning. Here's an example of an app created with Gemini 3.1 Pro that can simulate urban
planning to design completely new cities. Okay, so look at that. It's actually designing a city
around a geographic landscape. You have a bunch of different settings, everything from pathing,
path collision, water features, land features, and you can edit and modify them all. Here you can
actually see the city blocks being built. Look at how cool that looks. It's not only functional,
but it really looks cool. And it actually put together a synthesis. So it generated this image
of what that city might look like. Unreal. Maybe this is the future of SimCity right here. Okay.
This is one I am particularly interested in because I've been getting into 3D printing lately. This is
basically prompt a CAD model. So cool. Watch this. So write manifold CAD code to build this object
from the technical drawing. Okay. So basically all it provided was a technical spec of what it
look like and you probably don't even need that and it put it together and check this out there's
the object in cad fully created you are now able to basically create anything you want and 3d print
it so that's it go try it out let me know what you think if you enjoyed this video please consider
giving a like and subscribe and i'll see you in the next one